sarah vous écoute merci beaucoup déjà
merci de mobilité et je vous remercie à
tout ça par avance de votre attention
monsieur le professeur
je voulais commencer cette lettre par
des mots d'affection de reconnaissance
de tristesse et de sentiment d'avoir été
blessées dans mon intime mon histoire
comme si on avait touché à un de mes
profs comme si on avait tué la source de
mon savoir la source de ce qui m'a
permis d'être ce que je suis aujourd'hui
mais on vous a pleuré monsieur le
professeur et tout était dans nos larmes
et face à la gravité des enjeux que
notre société traverse et dont on a bien
conscience
ce sont des mots d'exigence que j'ai
envie de dire aujourd'hui nous devons
l'exigence de la connaissance
face à l'horreur de votre meurtre on a
vu où nous mène l'ignorance nous devons
l'exigence de la connaissance et de
combattre nos ignorances
alors après l'effroi de ce qui s'est
passé je me suis retroussé les manches
car j'étais je dois dire bien une
ignorante
à propos de ce qu'est le droit de
blasphème et de son intérêt et j'ai
appris j'ai vulgariser les choses ici je
suis désolé mais c'est justement tout le
but de mon entreprise j'ai appris qu'en
france il y à des siècles
il y a eu une religion d'état qui
faisait autorité qui était le
christianisme à l'époque on ne blaguait
pas à propos de dieu on ne blague pas
avec jésus et puis des gens se sont
battus pour avoir le droit de ne pas
croire
et comme ça ne suffisait pas dressé dans
son coin et de dire je ne crois pas ils
se sont mis à rire de dieu à se moquer
de dieu affaire des caricatures et parce
qu'ils se sont octroyé le droit de rire
de dieu en public
c'est ainsi qu'ils ont acquis de manière
véritable le droit de ne pas croire
rires de dieu en public ça prouvait
qu'on pouvait jouir de ce droit de
manière manifeste
ça a été une longue bataille et on a
gagné ce droit
et puisqu'on n'était plus obligé de
croire en ce dieu
on a eu le droit de pouvoir croire en
d'autres dieux puisque l'on s'est moqué
de la religion on a eu le droit d'avoir
d'autres religions en france
en fait c'est parce qu'on a eu le droit
de blasphémer
qu'on a eu le droit de croire en ce que
l'on veut ou pas le droit de blasphème
ça a été fondateur le droit de blasphème
ça protège en fait la liberté de culte
et la diversité des cultes moi je n'ai
pas eu la chance de vous avoir comme
professeur ni d'avoir votre délicatesse
pour pouvoir me reprendre tout ça à
travers votre noble discipline qu'est
l'histoire et qui permet de comprendre
les fondements de tant de choses mais
avant même quand je n'avais pas compris
tout ça même quand je n'en avais même
pas encore saisi toute la portée
j'acceptais et je respectais ce droit de
blasphème
parce que j'avais confiance en fait en
mon pays en ses institutions en ces
règles du vivre ensemble et dans le bien
fondé de ces règles ce qui n'empêche pas
l'esprit critique mais au moins avoir un
terreau de confiance ça permet justement
de pouvoir débattre de pouvoir discuter
et quand je pense à cette jeune élève
qui s'est méfié de votre enseignement et
qui s'est empressé d'aller vous dénoncez
à son père quand je pense que je repense
à cette vidéo où je la vois dire ces
mots il pense qu'on n'est pas égale à e
je me pose la question c'est qui euh
c'est qui nous qu'est-ce qu'il ya mis
tout ça dans la tête
la réalité c'est qu'il y a des gens qui
me veulent mettre de la confusion ce
qu'ils veulent faire c'est de mettre
tous dans le même sac
ils veulent mettre tous le nom sous le
nom de l'islamophobie une agression
raciste c'est puni par la loi
un acte de vandalisme d'un lieu de culte
c'est puni par la loi
et ils veulent me le mettre sur le même
plan qu'une caricature
et dire que ceux de que c'est de
l'islamophobie alors que c'est
sensiblement antagonistes ils veulent
semer la confusion pour créer un
sentiment d'être attaqué de partout
une agression raciste c'est puni par la
loi
un lieu de culte vandalisés comme il y
en a eu dans différentes mosquées c'est
puni par la loi
et ça doit l'être avec fermeté car la
loi protège la liberté de culte mais une
caricature ça fait partie de la laïcité
nous devons le discernement et en votre
mai
noir nous devons toutes ces exigences et
je n'oublierai jamais votre visage notre
très cher sa mère bravo là et je devrais
lire 1 mais élève dès la rentrée votre
texte merci beaucoup
il est papa merci mais reveillère si
sarah merci d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir plus merci l'aller 2-2 de sarah
leur fatiha vous je trouve ça elle a été
enseignante c'est à dire qu'elle a fait
preuve de pédagogie elle n'est pas resté
sur le registre enregistrement de
l'émotion il ya eu de l'émotion
parce que là c'est une figure familière
qui est attaquée et d'une manière
horrible c'est l'enseignant mais quand
elle explique d'où vient cette loi de
séparation de l'église d'où vient le
lien entre le droit de critiquer et le
droit d'être différent d'avoir une autre
religion
et finalement ce qui tu sais jamais la
caricature et l'auf ans c'est
l'islamophobie ne tue dans ce pays que
ceux qui en sont accusés et je le
rappellerai à fait isa tout à l'heure
c'est un très beau texte